thank you
[Music]
did you hear about what happened to
those Marines on San Clemente Beach I
saw a headline and I scrolled right
after what what was the headline it's
your brothers I saw it except for five
brother yeah so uh number five Dallas
brother this is an interesting thing so
so uh of course like as you check out my
brothers that's why but keep going the
story uh the story changed a little bit
first time that I saw the article it
said oh three Marines uh claimed to have
been hanging out at the beach in San
Clemente they saw a group of rowdy kids
like 40 teenagers hanging out
um setting off fireworks and then one of
the debris off fireworks hit one of the
Marines so he you know went over and
asked the kids to stop setting off
fireworks on the beach because you're
not supposed to do that anyway yeah and
then uh basically they then said that
that mob of 40 teens ended up getting
upset with them for stepping up to them
and then they just beat them up
that's Story one oh and not one teenager
was injured
I because they could have taken at least
like 10 of them down
no like I guess in that first iteration
do you think you could beat up oh I
think so too what was the story so so
what
so what I think so well like I think Ron
could beat a lot of people yeah dude is
there a video or something or like
there's a video about the company of
that particular thing happening yeah I
picked wrong
if it was all of us versus [__] 40
teenagers
that's that's pretty that's pretty scary
40 people is a lot 40 people yeah 40 of
anything is a lot all of us hit hard
enough to hurt a teenager all right but
team could be like 17 it could be like
full grown or whatever yeah so did
Marines get into a rumble with teenagers
um in the video right the video that
they watched the video okay and then I
saw one like that I think they're
walking upstairs yeah and then one of
them did someone throw something at them
or something like that and he turns
around so he runs into the group
socks a team or one of the kids but as
soon as he socks him four other like one
come from the side and then you just see
them just disappear
bad strategy you just gotta keep going
well how would you handle 42. beat up 40
kids one at a time hurricane you don't
go in the middle of the crowd because
that's where you get jumped you have to
be able to square up to everybody so as
they approach
but really you you dropped you dropped
two or three people it sends a freaking
message true like when they fall to the
floor like lifeless like it's a scary
sounds like he's done that
I was like he knows I don't know if I've
ever lifeless somebody yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'd punch somebody and they go oh
good shot and then they punch me right
back but he's like I guess they were a
teenager yeah
that's the curse words
how many marines were there three three
and 40 teenagers yeah
our military is going to [__] man there
is a video that I saw where the Marines
were clearly trying to walk away from
the group yeah and then one kid like ran
up and socked him in the back of his
head so then he turned around and then
they all just like that might be the one
you saw too that's the one I saw yeah
the earliest one to come out how did you
feel when you saw that video were you
like [__] you're supposed to be
Warriors why are you losing to these
kids so there's a lot of feelings at the
time so there's one where it's like um
because you don't know what phase of
this Marine is in his career is he
someone that's like upper ranking is he
in the middle of his career and if he's
like just graduated boot camp I'm almost
on the kids side because the ones that
just graduated boot camp because I
remember I remember having that feeling
I remember like graduating boot camp you
feel so [__] Invincible like you feel
like you need to be the [__]
righteous Warriors of the world so me
and my boys would be like let's just go
somewhere and see if we can get into a
fight it just [__] some fools up
because you're like you just went
through this whole giant write-up
passage you feel like you could do
anything so I'm like if you caught those
Marines they're probably the ones that
have like
if there are fireworks going on and it
hits them you can just go somewhere else
you don't have to be like aha here's my
chance to tell someone right you know
what I mean so it depends if it was like
they're true mid-career Marines were uh
they're just minding their own business
or whatever and then they get to the
fight like depending on the career of
the Marine they have a different
reaction and demeanor you know and like
my guilty meter goes like whether like I
believe in them or they [__] up or you
know it's funny that you say that
because I I ran into guys just like that
when I was 17. I was at a parade for
like you know when like uh Montebello
will do like the marching band stuff
yeah I went out to like one of the
parades that are competing and these
like three Marines came up to me and I
was wearing a like an army jacket
yeah and um I didn't know that they
didn't like that but uh yeah one one guy
went up to me and he was like hey take
that jacket off right now because he's
like [__] loser I was like bro like I
was like I was 17 I was like bro it's a
problem and he was like he goes you know
how many Blood Sweat and Tears I'm gonna
[__] earn it earning the right to
wear that [__] and then I and I said I
was like dude I got it at the Army
Surplus Store because it was just a
cheap jacket like a person that was
wearing it they died yeah so yeah they
died because they because they sucked
their combat yeah so I took it it's mine
now and he was just like that good they
wouldn't have been dead they were like
they were like two like there was three
of them two of them were like super
pissed and they were really big and then
um and then I didn't want to take it off
because like I was a little [__] too
so I was like uh no I'm not taking it
off and then and then that guy goes he
is I'll never forget what he's saying he
goes um yeah well I suggest you
reconsider that because when I get angry
I tend to break things oh dude get the
[__] out of here you're in a 1980 Steven
seagull movies yeah he's like an 80s
bully yeah yes I turned green that's the
thing like you don't those guys probably
just graduated boot camp and then so
they're like because they were like
younger yeah yeah they're talking [__]
to these kids and then these kids are
like
see there would be and then I I turned
to the third guy who was like kind of
off to the side they're all three of
them Marines and I go do you also agree
with this [__] and the guy just went
because real like people that have
actually been in it for a while they
don't give a [__]
you know what I mean like when they when
they view they're like a kid I was just
like if they've been in a marine for a
while and like that's their job job now
yeah they just see it as like oh yeah I
work at like a [__] a t or whatever
like that's just part of their thing
they're not like so tied to it that's
not their identity and they're probably
like oh that's cool that's probably
Vietnam era camo it's pretty cool oh
that's desert storms tight that would
have been a nice conversation yeah yeah
but then they're like
well it wasn't that no no not military
related but it was a guy it was tough
guys it was tough guys coming to me like
trying to start a fight and I was like I
was like look I don't have time for this
right now do not make me get my [__]
ass beat right now
no one to two am I gonna have to really
get like stop what I'm doing right now
and get my [__] ass kicked and they
didn't know what they had no idea
I was at a bar I sat in this one place
and like apparently somebody had just
left to go in the bathroom they came
back and then he like was like Hey dude
I was sitting there and I was like am I
really gonna have to get my [__] ass
kicked over this
and yeah they just didn't know what to
do that's just so it was like I could
see their brain misfire and there's like
there were two like I think like drunk
to like even that wasn't really a
challenge like
well I don't want to kick your ass now
yeah yeah exactly especially on like a
low IQ life form he'd be like
it was it was thankfully they were drunk
yeah enough to not be crazy that's so
funny I'm also disappointed that three
Marines got their ass kicked by case too
well hey that's the funny part to me
it's sad because in the video that the
one that initially came out the dude the
marina turned around and tried to fight
he ends up in a fetal position on the
ground while they're just kicking the
[__] out of damn and it's really like
yeah and thank you they were like
[__] Sailors or something
right so you look closely there's a
marine tattoo in one of their lower
backs
Marines had this reputation
of like Untouchable almost yeah because
if you go to San Diego and all these
camps everyone [__] hates them
because they're out there bar fighting
all the time yeah Okinawa too right
you're just like [__] Marines man no
class just brute [__] always
fighting that's the interesting part of
this so a couple days later more video
comes out that shows so according to
their story the three of them were just
hanging out at the beach but then more
video comes out showing them partying on
the beach almost like they because the
kids testimony was that they tried to
join their party
that's cool so that sounds more like
Marine Behavior here's a video of what
they were doing in school after you've
been gone for a couple years just
chilling on the beach yeah yeah that's
one day chilling on the beach
Fireball Fireball so the kids said they
were drunk and belligerent so there the
kids said that they were play fighting
with each other
like they're rough houses
and then one kid got in it and they they
like pushed the kid and that's when it
like escalated
this is before the video that you know
remember what I told you depending on
what career they're in yeah I will be
like I more for them or again that looks
like some fresh out of boot camp drunk
boys boot camp like one or two years in
you have a you're working mess dude
we're looking [__] mess but the chip
on your shoulder you think you're above
it or so badass yeah like I think that's
them and then I'm like they probably
deserve it that's that's interesting
because I didn't I didn't know there was
a distinction for a while after that
happened to me I was like [__] Marines
man they're [__]
take my jacket off but imagine if they
came up to you if you were like a 6'5
dude you think they would come up to you
and give you [__] if I was skinny and
Filipino still yeah or if I [__] in
Stone Cold Steve Austin came in with the
camera you don't say that [__] today
exactly yeah that's so cool dude yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they just
clearly picking on me I think also
because I had weird hair so they were
just like oh he's a nerd or some [__]
you know but yeah this has now come out
and now you're they're getting testimony
from all these different kids
um because they arrested like five or
six of the kids so far and then those
kids are saying that no we actually got
injured uh we were defending ourselves
these guys hit in the face you just came
and tried to punk us is what they're
saying
so it's kind of hard to say what what
really happened so it's three against
40. and and they and they were seen
parting with them previously exactly
because they didn't say that it's a
little different than what they didn't
they didn't didn't say that in their
initial story it's just like Marines got
killed because they got beat up because
they're Marines and San Clemente's
taking it really really seriously
because San Clemente is a very Pro like
you know it's a huge military Town yeah
yeah and they want is there a base there
there's navy bases there's a Marine base
there's uh because you know the funny
thing is if you listen to any Police
Department that has a base nearby they
[__] hate military guys oh because at
night they're the ones causing all the
[__] at the bars and everything yeah so
let's say that that happens and a marine
causes a problem and then the cops come
do they just go oh you're a marine yeah
go ahead just go back to base like do
they do they let them off easy it
depends on the cop it's really
individual
and um since body cams
yeah yeah and it depends yeah it depends
like on what they're doing too you know
okay what if it's just like fighting
I don't think so I think they'd probably
get in trouble yeah dude body cams
change to everything and then like some
some stuff is like big no-nos like
during like uh [__] what I forgot the
word where you're like off on the
weekend furlough yeah something like
that where you like if you fight on the
weekend
um the civilian cops will take you in
and then you have to deal with the
military police and they have their own
charges and MP are pretty crazy right
well like the the the repercussions are
way crazier so for example like let's
say you get in some big trouble and you
get taken in they can reduce your rank
and when if they reduce your rank it can
go from like it's not just like jail
time or whatever like let's say you're
making three G's a month it can go down
to 1500 a month wow and there's military
jail that they throw you in so it
affects you big time yeah yeah we
[__] around like you don't want to
really cut your salary like that you
want to [__] around yeah oh so that's
the incentive to be have Good Conduct
outside I know a guy who he was
stationed abroad
he was drinking and driving I guess
right but it was like under the U.S
legal limit but like over there it was
like within the boundaries of like
what's [__] up for them yeah and so
like he almost same thing like had his
pay slash like 3x
yeah so based on your knowledge of
marine guys like cold knowledge of of
what you've been through and socially
how they are what do you think is the
likeliest thing that happened here
the like listing see how they have their
shirts off and how young they are they
probably and Fireball yeah yeah they
probably wanted to be like the Big Man
on Campus and let's let's [__] you
know like show these guys on a drink no
[__] tough we are dude because you're
like dudes that are like actually been a
marine for like 10 years they're career
people they're probably at home with
their wife or something yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah these guys are like
I'm a [__] what what these chicks get
wet when I [__] tell them I'm a
marine you know like
according to both sides they did say
they were Marines
yeah yeah and they're doing Fireball so
they're like like hey uh so these
teenagers think that fireball is kind of
spicy hey how about another shot over
here
I'm a [__] United States Marine
foreign